être curieux c'est bien être
correctement informés c'est mieux il
faut donc se méfier des applications
d'identification de champignons loin
très loin d'être fiables surtout
lorsqu'il s'agit de les consommer du
champion
l'humain est bien plus crédible envoyer
tout de suite c'est ce qu'on appelle une
amanite parce qu'il y à une volvo est la
base du pied oui c'est le petit cible
géo 30
kate avons comestibles en d'autres
termes albert s'y connaît eh bien oui
les mycologues un scientifique
spécialisé dans les champignons
j'ai commencé j'avais l'ageval six ans
jean ley 81,2 quand même pas mal
depuis quatre mois en france 732
personnes ont été intoxiquées en
mangeant des champignons non comestible
la faute principalement la confiance
aveugle en ses applications c'est aussi
connaît pas c'est pas internet qui va
vous aider à donner à nos exact
normalement on dit que ce sont les
pharmaciens qui sont plus aptes à vous
renseigner bon mais mais albert n'est
pas convaincu
tout simplement parce que les
pharmaciens ne suive au maximum que 60
heures de formation à la mycologie et à
la toxicologie au cours de leur cursus
et puis en cette période de grippe
difficile d'en trouver de disponible
alors la meilleure solution c'est albert
qui vous la donne embrasser bondé faut
manger des champions que l'on laisse
sûrs de connaître et surtout qu'ils ont
été identifiés comme il faut